It sounds like Walters wrists
are getting better and
adding users is a big turning point for
the app congratulations.
Whoa Laila you look terribly tired.
Is everything okay,
when's the last time you slept?
>> Yeah it's been awhile.
We do a lot more user data now but
I'm not sure it's anything to celebrate.
Still struggling with just
exactly how to implement sharing.
Walter asked for sorting data.
And, well, that's pretty easy to
filter and sort our shopping lists.
As it is it makes me think of bigger and
badder looming questions.
>> And what are those?
>> I'm just I'm terrified about
what happens when we start getting
thousands of users.
I know too many as it
isn't a problem right now.
Heck it's even hard to
get my roommates and
Nana to use the app
in its current state.
But the decisions they make about
data now will affect the future.
Our current model we made was
somewhat randomly put together.
Without any rigorous
thinking about performance.
I'm not even sure what the best way to
dissociate users and shopping lists is.
>> Yeah I could see how
that could be stressful.
Why don't you walk me through the exact
kind of functionality you are working on
in and worried about.
>> [SOUND] Let me pull the wire frames.
So we could have the settings activity
show different sorting options.
And then on the items page,
we could differentiate between the
bought items and the non bought items.
The bought items would
all be on the bottom and
crossed out instead
of mixed in randomly.
As for how the data of the firebase
database itself should be organized,
I just don't know.
Finally, I want to implement some
sort of sharing functionality.
Right now all the lists are world
viewable which doesn't make a lot of
sense when we get tons of users.
What I'd like to happen is
that the users can make lists.
But they're private until
their shared with other users.
>> Do you know what the sharing
flow will look like???
>> So I was thinking something
like a user can add friends and
then once a friend is added.
They can click a little check mark box
to show whether the list is being shared
with that friend or not.
And I was thinking of trying
to filter to allow for
basic auto complete functionality.
>> Well the first part where
you sort of list sounds easy.
Firebase has some basic filtering and
sorting function I built into it.
So you shouldn't worry
too much about that.
>> [SOUND] So what do you think?
Can we tackle sorting?
I can make the UI screens.
>> You know what,
why don't you take it easy for a bit.
I'll chat with the developer
about sorting.